before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
this is kind of a big one to go over
again
I'll say up front I'm bias and Joe
Martin's favor
[Music]
yes folks fugitive of the Dune remember
when this landed how earth-shattering it
was at the time oh boy this was such a
huge deal this episode and revisiting it
is a little odd because I'll just be
upfront about this and I'll try not to
dwell on it over the rest of the review
a lot of the excitement and enthusiasm
at least that I had for this episode
came from a hope of all the
possibilities
the potential stories to be told in
explaining exactly where the fugitive
doctor fits into the doctor's timeline
since the implication is that this
doctor either comes in between other
incarnations but has been erased which
doesn't fit other stuff we already know
about Doctor Who at least it didn't at
the time we've since learned other stuff
Timeless child makes it all weird but
um
initially
you know those all 13 incarnations which
technically ran through Matt Smith and
then we had a a um a recharge on the
regenerations you know all those uh
incarnations were accounted for so there
wasn't really a place to put her so the
implication being she was pre-hardinal
so if she's pre-heart no why doesn't she
why does she have a Tardis in the shape
of a police box I mean if she doesn't
know what the Sonic Screwdriver is she
has to at the latest be between Hartnell
and trouten because trouton had the
Sonic Screwdriver but
this all kind of went nowhere I mean
even just the idea of getting to see
more of Joe Martin's doctor got me
excited regardless of what the specifics
of what her backstory were going to be
and we got
very little of that two she makes a
couple more appearances down the line
that don't amount to much at all
so
I'm going into this as a re-watch and it
already has a major knock against it
because
I know all the potential
that this idea and this casting
especially had is wasted even with the
idea that chipmunk did what he wanted to
do if this was all he ever wanted to do
would The Fugitive doctor is what he did
what a waste
what a waste of an idea and what a waste
of an amazing bit of casting
so as I said I will try not to stay on
that point as I go through it but
understand that it already jumps down a
not insignificant amount in my
estimation due to the fact that it loses
the um the excitement and the Mystique
of oh where is this going I now know
where it's going
which is mostly nowhere
and so as a result I have to take this
very much as a piece unto itself now
regardless of what I just said and it
dropping in my estimation
it's still not a bad episode in and of
itself and taking out you know
excitement or disappointment about what
happens later out of the equation it's
still pretty decent All Things
Considered first of all let me just gush
about Joe Martin again she is great
immediately Ruth as a character is
immediately endearing and charismatic
she holds the screen even before you
know getting her old personality back
she holds the screen very well she
brings a lot of personality and just a
few scenes I liked her immediately so
she's already delivering a really good
enjoyable character even before we get
later on and we get to see her say hello
I believe you I believe you immediately
the way she says it the presence that
she has and I like just little tiny
moments that she has like when
when uh later on when Jody Whitaker's
doctor confronts her for pointing a gun
at somebody and Jody Whitaker goes the
doctor would never shoot anybody and and
Joe Martin goes I know
so she's more deceptive and more widely
than the Jody Whitaker doctor is who is
a bit more upfront uh and sincere which
also makes their scenes together good
because they have very different energy
and it plays off well when they kind of
bounce off each other so pretty much
everything to do with Joe Martin oh you
know what's you know what is a moment
that I've forgotten about but I love
it's this moment where after she gets
the text from Lee and it kind of brings
briefly the doctor to the Forefront and
she sort of confronts the jidoon it's
like instinct against the bullies it's a
great moment it's a great just summation
of the doctor in general instinctively
taking on the bullies So within this
episode pretty much everything that Joe
Martin does I love
I'm so a little better that we didn't
get more from her but like again moving
on uh the jadun
uh it's it's a bit of a recycle job I
mean not only is their presence uh you
know very similar their methodology is
virtually identical to last time they
showed up the only difference is they
didn't bother to transport people to the
Moon first this time which like is fine
they're not really the main focus but it
does feel uh like chipmunk has nothing
to add to their appearance and it's just
using them in the exact same way that
they got used in Smith and Jones I will
note that the lip sync on the mouth
movements significantly better here than
it was before they got a lot better at
that
negative and the episode overall it it
has a good build as we meet Ruth we meet
Lee we see Lee being Squirrely and we
assume there's something up with him and
then the surprise for theoretically on
first viewing at least for both the
audience and the doctor no Lee's not who
they're there for and again Joe Martin
bringing like she does scared Ruth
really well but then she's so commanding
with the doctor the build and the
trajectory of all that is actually
pretty well done it's hard to say that
it's a completely satisfying story on
its own because
taken as a whole it doesn't really have
a solid conclusion again it feels like
it is introducing a big idea to do
something with later and then just
largely didn't I know I said I wasn't
gonna harp on this it just I just can't
help but keep circling back to it but
trying to keep off of that we also have
the return of Captain Jack Harkness now
I'm not gonna go into any thoughts on
John Barrowman that I have at this point
I covered a lot of what was going on
with him years ago my opinions haven't
really changed so just understand not
dealing with any of that so as far as
his appearance goes
it's kind of pointless like honestly
it's it's Nostalgia bait and Barrowman
brings that energy in that presence that
makes him fun to have on screen but he
effectively does nothing
he Yanks the companions onto his ship
briefly and interacts with them doesn't
meet the doctor has no impact on the
plot that's actually going on right now
and basically is just a Nostalgia bomb
drop that is also the mechanism by which
we introduce and tease the idea of the
lone Cyberman
and I think teasing the coming of the
lone supplement is a good thing to do it
just feels like a little bit of a waste
to burn off the return of Jack Harkness
in order to do that
considering that he again really does
nothing and there's so much Nostalgia a
bit like how the Dune were recycled
doing the exact same thing with the
exact same methodology as the last time
there's a lot of recycling with Jack as
well because like he's got to mention
the Nano genes
[Music]
because yeah again and like he's on a
ship that he stole again and of course
you know the standard stuff that I would
have expected to be recycled like how
flirtatious he is hitting on everybody
like that fine but it's just all these
nostalgic hits a lot of which again seem
to have no reason to be there other than
to be hits of nostalgia and look I can
give a certain amount of leeway with
hits of nostalgia but like they're piled
on excessively here to be blunt about it
and ultimately as I said other than
deliver the teas that the lone cyber
man's coming he doesn't do anything of
substance or of meaning or of relevance
and that wouldn't have been a problem if
he himself got better payoff down the
line and he doesn't really like he will
come back and I'll address that when I
get to it but that really has almost
nothing to do with his appearance here
so it's just okay there he there he was
that was fun
why though you don't necessarily need a
deep reason to bring back a character
that people love but generally if you're
going to do it for no reason other than
the fun of bringing them back I would
say you do that while having them be the
primary focus of the episode so the
whole episode is just about isn't it fun
having this character back for a bit but
he's not that he's on a single set in a
couple of scenes it's just
odd
not bad necessarily but an odd use I
think maybe the thing to compare it with
is with the return of the master with
Sasha Dewan which was also in many ways
a big hit of nostalgia not just bringing
the master back but we bring back the
tissue compression which hasn't been
seen since the 70s I don't think well no
80s it did show up again in the 80s but
like it's been decades since that thing
has come up and the master is also in
many ways a hit of nostalgia but like
there's context for the master so like a
whole big thing with series 11 was that
it was meant to be more accessible to
new viewers
um who weren't following Doctor Who up
to that point and the way the master is
introduced while it is very clear that
he has history with the doctor within
the confines of spyfall Parts one and
two he is given full and proper context
of who he is and why he matters it is
explained this was the the doctor's best
friend they have been confronting each
other for a very long time and for the
purposes of that story The that's really
all the context you need and honestly he
arguably even works better without old
contacts from previous series because we
still don't actually know where dewan's
Master Falls timeline wise but if he
does come after Missy uh he probably
works a little bit better if you don't
know Missy and know that Missy kind of
had an arc where she wasn't
fighting the doctor anymore and now
suddenly he is but again like my
asterisks on that is hey we don't
actually know where he falls in the
Master's timeline and B I am actually
more forgiving of this now given that uh
there's sort of the self-loathing layers
to that character that we're pretty well
established by the time he wrapped up
but I got I ended up tangenting but okay
so the reason I brought that up is that
is also a big hit of nostalgia big
returning villain
but the difference between that and
bringing Jack back is there is no
context given for Jack he just shows up
says that he knows the doctor doesn't do
anything
drops a line that'll mean something in a
couple of episodes and then leaves
whereas the master while also being
ahead of nostalgia
was a major focus a little bit to the
detriment of that story as I said in
those reviews but like he gets proper
focus and enough context that he works
and you're not left going wait why
should I care about this person Jack
they don't bother with that leg work
which is odd and so overall what we have
is a actually still kind of fun a little
bit of a roller coaster episode but that
ultimately
a lot of the strength of it was in the
excitement of what it might mean and
that is now gone it just is I've got a
handful of other small things to point
out both good and bad so why don't we do
that I feel like the timing for the
death of Lee is really good happens
about halfway into the episode so it's a
real interesting twist that the whole
story pivots on and then we get the
reveal the fugitive doctor soon after I
also like that Lee gets referred to as
her faithful companion and this is
before we know who Ruth is and know
about the fugitive doctor so that's a
cool little tease that about what's
coming up we have the character of Gat
who I think works for a division it
doesn't matter she doesn't survive to
the end of this which is weird I feel
like it would have made a lot more sense
to plant her as a recurring thing and
maybe even make use of her instead of
the eventual reveal of tech taeyoon
which really goes nowhere but yeah sure
let's use this person to introduce this
whole idea and then immediately kill
them there's this really weird bit where
the Tardis gets pulled up in a tractor
beam and as we're literally watching the
Tardis get pulled up by a tractor beam
they have the fugitive doctor say
yeah we know we're we're what would you
it was like I turned on uh audio
capturing for the for the uh difficult
of seeing like I know
I know that's what they're doing I'm
watching it what that's that was that
stuck out to me so much this time I
already mentioned uh The Fugitive doctor
having the whole thing with like I know
shut up with the weapon but I like that
she goes to threatening while uh you
know giving the little hint that she
wasn't actually intending to kill
anybody threatening with a weapon
whereas Jody Whitaker's doctor tries to
disarm the situation by being honest and
you can see that Clash because the
fusion of doctors like shut up what are
you doing you are so stupid and so I'd
like that interaction is fun that's an
interesting Clash I think the other
thing there's a there's a little note
earlier on where the doctor
um Jody Whitaker's doctor describes the
uh the fam as a flat team structure
that'll come up later and also we um
kind of open with the doctor closed off
and kind of being called out for this
um by the companions you lost too many
questions
maybe because we're worried about you
I mean one minute you're all smiles next
minute your mind's somewhere else this
is valid she is closed off she doesn't
always share but it's also a little odd
because we've gone a couple of episodes
since the end of spyfall that seemed to
set off like them being really concerned
about the fact that she wasn't sharing
but we've had two whole Adventures where
that didn't matter and now all of a
sudden it does uh that I feel like that
should have been sprinkled across the
previous episodes or should have been
done less bluntly uh Sledgehammer to the
face style here uh bringing it back up
and they do kind of circle back to it
again at the end with the doctor being
very flat out like you don't know me and
that's true and that's a part of this
doctor that I've had to come to terms
with over time that she is very bad at
sharing like she loves to be around
people
she hates to share
uh you know anything about herself
she'll share her enthusiasm her
knowledge
not stuff about herself though
and we do get it reminded here which it
needs to be but again with that gap of a
couple episodes where it just didn't
come up is odd and I think that's just
where I'm going to kind of leave it
there are parts of this that are still
good there are parts of this that are
honestly still great there are other
parts that are
just kind of weird or just don't work as
well now that we know this isn't really
going anywhere which is a shame because
I remember how exciting this was at the
time
but what are your thoughts about this
fugitive of the Dune you rewatched it
lately whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
you get uh rewards for every tier
including Early Access up to a week
before these videos go live and that's a
benefit you get at any tier and there's
other benefits besides even if you can't
like share subscribe also help me out
but uh don't worry about it too much
what I really want you to remember is
you are beautiful
you're valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I gotta shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore stupid fulla
Tarak the thing that goes doink in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjarnison Linda
Walters kimudelki the oatha Boyd katoria
toy lowly Becky Sparks for nabilox the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Jayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]